Hello everybody, this is Dr. Connors and I want to explain a little bit about how our process works, what we offer,
how we can support you along your way or health journey.
So let's kind of walk through this. First, let's describe. We really are a ministry. We really believe that
we want to be God-centered, Christ-centered, and
in everything we do, we pray about if we're gonna make recommendations for you and how we're gonna handle you
and you'll see that through our courses.
Not here to offend anybody, but I'm not gonna pretend I'm not somebody that I'm not. So that is a big part of what we do
and we believe that God is your healer and
sister of life and
we want to be bold about that declaration.
Now many people start with us really just by starting with our courses.
So I believe one of my ministries is to what I when I learned something and I'm kind of addicted to learning
and I do believe that God put that desire in my heart to constantly be seeking
asking questions, constantly be
educating myself, but not for myself. I think that knowledge can just puff up.
I believe that he gave me that desire so that I can then
take that information,
break it down into the simplest terms.
I hope I do a good job of that and educate other people so that they can get better, so that they can deal with
with their life, with what the struggles that we're dealing with. And I believe we are living in an age where
we can't always rely on a clinic or a doctor to take care of us anymore. It's getting crazy
in this world. And we need to have knowledge to be able to better our lives and better our family's lives, especially in the
toxic, toxic climate that we're living in. So I've created a bunch of courses so far. I have six as of this recording.
You might have come to this site because of live disease, the three phases of live disease might be the best course for you.
Most people come to this site because they have chronic disease.
Maybe already diagnosed with autoimmune disease. I believe that very soon pretty much everybody's going to end up with an autoimmune
diagnosis. And it has to do with the vaccines that are out there, it has to do with the chemicals that were exposed to the
toxins that were exposed to our food sources, blah, blah, blah. It is just, it's just inevitable. So our body responds by making
antibodies and we need to know how to deal with that. We have a course on our genetics called your read your genes course.
The seven phases of detoxification based upon my book with the same title, frequency healing course based upon the
right machine. And our flagship for our cancer site is our stop fighting cancer course because that's what really
God led me to help people with the most serious disorder and that is cancer. Now a lot of people start with just the courses.
Really, I didn't even put a slide into this, but most people start with having a conversation with me. So you could do an
initial consultation with me a 15 minute consult and I could help point you maybe in the best direction. I don't know what
course to take. I don't know what to do. What should I do? We'll have a consultation with me and I can point you in the
best direction. Then from the courses that people want more personalized care, they can choose some other options. And you'll see on
this website, we have a page with your other options that you can choose. Some people purchase a fully program, right?
But she already know what they got going on. They've already been to other doctors. They have their nutrition figured out such they
just want to get a right machine. Some people want a full nutritional protocol. So they're going to join our full private
membership. Some people want to do just a genetic workup. That's the thing that they're missing with the genetic workup. You get
their read your genes course for free. But the most intimate relationship we have with people is if you join as a full private
member, full private member has access to my weekly zoom calls where they're live weekly zoom calls where you can ask
questions live to me. You can submit your questions on our full member only website. The full member only website has a lot
information that we can't have on a public site. So it's a great way to have that intimate private relationship with us that we
can help you as best we can. So with the right machine purchase, you actually get the frequency healing course for free. It comes with everything that
you'll need for the right machine. A lot of people choose this first. They've done their studies on right technology and they just
really want to get a right. They know what they're missing. So surprisingly, a lot of people just jump in and get this.
We have tons of people and I've done 1000 plus genetic reviews over the years. Starting with a full genetic workup could be a great
choice as well. With the genetic workup, we call our genetic review. You get our read your genes course. And it is packed full of information. You will become a genetic
expert going through that course. But again, like I said, our flagship is our full private membership. That's where you really have personalized relationship with me. And we can really put together a protocol. It's where we do
cheek swab testing. With the full membership, you actually get access to all our courses for free. That's included in the full membership. And the weekly zoom calls that I talked
you about. And they're all recorded. And they're all put up on the website. So there's just tons of stuff on the member site for you. Our belief really is to keep digging. You know, I don't think I have the answer to everything. I, you know, I, I need to be asking God for those answers. That's what wisdom is. And so do you. And we just, you know, when you're trying to figure out a complex case, you have to keep asking questions.
And trying different things and working towards a resolution and continuing to learn and study. So that's our purpose for you. We want you the best things for you. And maybe that's not working with us. So maybe starting with a
initial consultation is the best way. And I may say whatever you're doing is right. Stay with whoever you're working with and what you're doing. I might say, you know, start with a course. I don't know. Well,
everybody's different. So we want to seek out what's best for you. And that's what our purpose is. So thank you so much. No, I'm praying for you. And continue to use our site. How every you need to. Bye bye.